bien brasseur dans la faune du théâtre
vous êtes un aigle bicéphale vont
présenter cette trace tout de même assez
extraordinaire de l'acteur auteur aux
auteurs n'ont pas ce que j'ai écrit oui
beaucoup de pièces je lui beaucoup de
juifs à peu près tout mais elle était
mal foutu enfin changerait vous qui le
dites vous en en juin j'étais mal faite
non elle était comme ça je t en vitesse
et mes jeux j'aurais évidemment préféré
lire d'avoir le temps de travailler mais
j'ai été pris par mon vrai métier
d'acteur mais là j'ai trouvé le temps
certains auraient vraiment alors là
vraiment j'avais pris commencé il ya six
ans comme ici dans lesquels m'enfin je
dire foutu en l'air j'ai commencé je
travaille et puis finalement j'ai pensé
que que c'était un sujet vraiment
actuelle est que tout le monde
connaissait une situation que tout le
monde le connaissait
l'approché est amusant de faire nous
sommes dans la loge de réjeanne si
agréable de taiwo cissé risque elle a
dirigé le théâtre de paris
et voilà sa petite fille simplement je
vois que vous la connaissez l'adage est
une personne dans la pièce et où votre
faim dans la pièce chez nous qu'est ce
que c'est que cet enfant du dimanche
bref c'est l'histoire d'un gosse
trimballer entre père et la mère
alors qu'ils sont en désaccord qui
divergent sur les morceaux m
c'est ça et il est parfaitement tour mon
dieu il s'arrange feuillus soit il n'y a
pas les mêmes valeurs
c'est ça public de comprendre ce qu'il
ressent exactement et je t'aime peu en
dessous la fin il faut l'éviter de
messages et vera et jacqueline parraine
et votre famille
jouer avec on n'a pas joué avec permet
pour la première fois que vous avez la
chance à une les poser pour gagner en
irak pour divorce et voilà cette nuit
mais on y arrive on commente interpret
alors notre fils sarfati oui moi il
symphatie sa petite amie c'est à martel
la belle fille marguerite mars et malgré
de péri il ya des soirs où mon mari
c'est maurice biraud et puis 20 puis
c'est tout sans oublier quelques uns par
nos bambins du mano et arthur l'ex-amant
des ravalements la petite amie à 3 à
mérignies la fin de ta petite amie tant
qu'à faire je me suis dit c'est vraiment
en faire un gars qui gagnent le faire
vous êtes enfin du dimanche va durer de
longues semaines déplaire à paris